today we are delighted to be joined by
keith lee who's showing off duelist this
is a this is a new video game which is
coming out and was kick-started and it
looks pretty thank you thank you I said
I give you the hardest intro ever and
see how you did with it you passed thank
you nice work thanks very much for
joining us today man please explain the
Duelist to folks it's kind of like a
final fantasy tactics online competitive
that's a perfect that are ice okay solid
summary ok so do list is a squad-based
tactical combat game and we focus a
hundred percent on multiplayer
competitive ranked play so what was
popularized in warcraft 3 all the way to
week legends and hearthstone we've been
really focused on building matchmaking
putting a competitive set of tears and
leagues but really we grew up on final
fantasy tactics fire emblem and we
wanted to make sure that we could target
all the folks that love classic tactics
games it so that's really kind of that's
what we decided to do they are like
games that i would consider
predominantly single player experiences
one that you kind of you drive into like
you spend a lot of time involved in is
it is anyone tried to do this before not
so much and the reason why is that most
people love a single player campaign but
for us once you finish it it's over and
i think that multiplayer is usually
tacked on so we wanted to build a game
from the ground up to focus on
competitive ranked play I think that's
going to really excite people and have a
lot of longevity alright do list I've
seen the trailers the kickstart has been
up it's been wildly successful can we
actually have a look at the game yes
it's the top bright and about to hop
right into it and talk a little bit
about the game rules and how everything
works so I'm gonna hop right into the
game Danny yes duelist what do I keep
saying the Duelist oh no I thought
you're gonna say duelist oh cuz i use no
i put a bit of irish on it there that's
the Judas that's a that's a match three
gem game alright do list so in duelist
the winning you start out as a duelist
you play the role of a blood-borne
general and the whole concept here is
you actually have a set of cores which
is essentially mana or a p8 and it will
ramp up every turn as it ends and what
you can do is you have an action bar in
the bottom and you can pre-select
and decide on a bunch of different units
and battle spells to deploy on to a very
compressed tactical map we designed this
to be very very small so that when you
move you can jump and hop right into a
game the game should last less than 20
minutes you don't have to move around a
lot and it's really focus on tactical
gameplay so when i'm going to show you
guys right now is two different generals
you'll notice also that there are
certain tiles that look different and
these are core tiles and essentially
what it will do is I've you land on
these you will get power-ups or have
more ap or mana for you to use
randomized or is it the dossier center
coordinator for every single map and
every single place so for example right
now I can deploy a different unit around
here and it costs one core for me to
launch this guy out here but I'm out so
I'll end the turn and as you know i'm
playing actually against myself and so
as two versions of mighty that's called
i believe yes you'll be one version
victory that has a higher a low ranking
than the other because one of them is
going to beat one of the others okay
versions of myself so do you always
start with just two generals and then
from there your spawn yes you start out
with two generals you can deploy
different units and they all have
different associated costs you can cast
spells and you can also move them around
but when you do move them it also costs
AP so you can't just spam a bunch of
different units out there and do these
type of things so right now i'm using
this general i'm going to deploy a unit
right here and the turn and you'll
notice right here that he has as aura
and it's because this general has a
special ability so every unit will have
their own special ability and offers
defensive armor to any units that are
surrounding or nearby this general so in
this case he's protected I'm gonna move
this guy over here and love his hair our
guys worked on a rogue legacy and
there's just a lot of really cool
expressive animations that we've done
for this I'm going to launch this really
awesome guy who's a long-range
projectile guy see on the art art style
is I hope the car is over on the stream
as well it's kind of a nice blend
between like almost kind of like pixel
art but just loads of super nice like
effects happen yes yes we
wanted to take that iconic classic feel
of Fire Emblem and tactics but Mary this
a lot with the greatest and best
tactical CCGs so what do you also notice
it's right here we have an Arcanist
class and you could actually see his
range he can actually shoot and fire
across three tiles so right now I'm
gonna actually have the Megan ring mage
cast Chain Lightning spell so now he's
going to cast the spell and do some
damage but I want to take this guy out
really really quickly so I'm going to
change my turn and I'm going to try to
nail this guy before you start to do
more damage to my folks so I killed this
guy right here so it's a mental this
down sorry this battles playing out
immediately you're you're relying a lot
on your summoned units you know you're
not going right into head-to-head with
the general that's my guess the wind
condition is kill the opposing teams
general that's right what so so is that
sort of how these things play out people
you know it's what you've summoned that
you are predominantly fighting one yes
you're summoning a lot of different
units but you can customize your squad
so no squad will be the same there's
going to be an upper bound of 25 to 30
units that you bring in including battle
spells including battle units and so in
this case for example I brought in this
guy who is a faction specific unit and I
can actually fire right now and right
now I can actually fire cross and do my
civil damage across some of these folks
and when you say when you say you
customize your squads is that before the
game starts or you talk before so
there's a priest reading where are you
able to choose a lot of different units
and for for example right now I want to
lock this guy down because I'm gonna be
casting a lot of spells here so i can
actually cast an ice pillar that that
will land on this guy so now he's
actually stuck and he can't move oh yeah
i think you've got the stream open on
your laptop which if we're getting a bit
of play playback coming through the
speakers okay in while you're doing that
and what are my folks you've got any
questions all for Keith a bad do list by
all means dictum in the twitch chat
gamespot comments or hit us up on
Twitter and a
make sure to ask them in fact I think we
may have one here already and pad jello
sir asks you've any tips for advanced
play in the game for advanced matches
how scalable is are the battles in it
are we taught the games themselves get
harder the matches based on who's
involved in them or is it just players
guild vs. player skill yes so we spend a
lot of time building out matchmaking so
you're going to be always matched with
equally matched players but we also have
a lot of different modes we have single
player we have practice casual which is
asynchronous and we also have ranked
normal play where you can actually
pre-select your custom squad and we
actually have a fourth mode which is
ranked draft so what that does is it
automatically unlocks all the available
units and spells see available in the
entire collection of the game you can go
in and immediately hop into the game and
play ranked competitive games so there's
a lot of different modes that are
available for people so let me kind of
show you some of the other really great
effects here and some of the folks so
this is actually a unit called the
justice class for this faction which is
a song hi and what she does is she is
able to grab health from an enemy unit
and actually siphon it back to your
general and so in this case right now
I'm getting kind of schooled on the left
side and so I'm going to try to fire
right now have my Archer kind of hopped
back and she can actually hit further
away so that's kind of one of her
abilities but I'm a little scared of
this unit which is a sensible class yes
what you can ask me more it's absorb and
so I'm going to put my tank up in the
front to protect myself and kind of see
what happens here how many different M
classes are available to each one of
those seven classes perfection those are
specific but there's a hundred plus
different battle units and spells that
you can incorporate into your own custom
squad so there's an infinite number of
variations and based on how your units
and your abilities are drawn in the
action bar you can have a totally
different set of opening moves and so
I'll give you an example right here i'm
going to give this guy a speed ability
so now he can actually move further and
faster
I'm going to have a move up to the front
and he's not going to be aware that i
had this movement right here so what's
going to happen is I'm going to move the
sentinel class up here devour this tank
move this guy down to the bottom attack
this general and i'm going to show you
this really awesome move so right now
I'm a little bit scared so I'm going to
drop this thing called fire fall in this
spot because I don't want him to stay in
this manna tile right in this court I'll
and it will actually do a damage over
time area effect in this area Jimmy
Hoffa is that what just happened yeah
it's burning across this three by three
grid I want to get out of here so it's
going to damage me every single term but
the cool thing is this guy had packed in
a spell called void walk what it will do
is swap out the location of any of your
allies with the general so right now I
can switch and this guy is going to get
hurt but I don't care as much about this
and take that mag and sheila bair dime a
dozen you jerk i'm gonna move this guy
up let's make a new one all we go in
general on general right now boom yes
that was the last hit oh nice and
basically a version myself
congratulating them i say i get stuck at
Keith Keith one saw so these this is
just an overview of all the all the
different units there's a hundred plus
units lots of different factions we've
got some amazing stuff that we building
around the story in the world and that's
like you guys started the Kickstarter
for this like it's almost I think it's a
week left or something just let's three
four weeks ago starter you have about
eight days left okay we have a lot of
really exciting stretch goals including
mobile tablets the IC the next stretch
goal is that you're going to try and
crack it in a couple of different
languages as well couple languages we
want to have a lot more story elements
into our game and the big ones that we
really want to push force to get it onto
ps4 as well as the xbox one what's the
what's the current I'm launch platform
so right now we're going to be launching
on the web on windows mac and pete and
linux and the great thing is that this
will actually work on the brow
without plugins all right so the whole
idea is that since the session times are
really short we want people to open a
tab at work and to be able to play a
quick session you want people to not do
their jobs so they can play your game
let's just enjoy their work experience a
lot more and I mean the thing that is
really interesting to me about this as a
competitive and ever is that turn-based
action because so many games you sort of
referencing league of legends you know
Starcraft like these these competitive
these tactical competitive games are so
can be so intimidating based on like
just like actually per minute and match
length adjust the the sheer physical
skill of the players yes who sort of are
very good at them but with this it's
almost not at all about the physical
skill because it's just click this body
that box you have plenty of time for
your turn that's right it's all about
the mental that's really one of the
reasons why we wanted to build this game
because our team's getting a slightly a
bit older we don't have all the crazy
400 a PMS I can't compete but even
though we grew up on warcraft 3 and
count of strike but the ability to hit a
pixel and the box things is just a bit
harder so for us now this is a perfect
product where we can still be super
competitive we can invest our time we
have very limited time so we want to
make the game super short and at the
same time it's still like ranked and got
a lot of competitive play and you have
90 seconds to make your decision not not
half a second the asynchronous play
seems to be something that's getting way
more popular in terms of people playing
with work as well the ability to just do
your move and then head back to shut the
tab down it's really popular especially
for mobile tablets and things like that
and we offer that as well so you could
play multiple sessions and multiple
games with different people and it's
nice because you don't have the pressure
of 90 seconds to play the hardcore
ranked games so this is more of a casual
mode for people to practice as well and
so we want to offer that awesome
keithley counter play games thank you so
much for coming on and showing us duel
is there